so I'm Julie Michael Minh I'm a data
scientist at Zulily
and I'm here to talk to you about pandas
pipelines and custom transformers so
let's jump in with a little background
the pandas dataframe this pandas
dataframe is the sort of core data
structure in pandas a two dimensional
table it has labelled rows and columns
each of the columns can be a different
type which is really nice so we can have
a date column a numeric string column
all the same data frame in contrast
numpy numpy arrays require all of the
entries via the same types the rows are
labeled with an index this default
suggests the row numbers but you can
also use more complex indices so for
this talk I picked out a public data set
special events permits from the City of
Seattle so the City of Seattle has this
open data portal where they make a whole
variety of data sets open to the public
easy to download descriptions and you
should check this out if you want to
play around with some local data this
data set particular is applications
received and special events permits
issued by the special events office
office of economic development since
2014 so anytime there's some big special
events that they need permission from
the city to hold the organization will
submit an application and hopefully they
get it the data set was several years
long so I felt her to just 2016 and I
cleaned up the row names to lowercase
with underscore so let's take a look we
have this pandas dataframe will will
import with the CSV function and use had
to take a look at the first few rows
there's the application date permit
status looks like this first view we're
all complete permit type looks like the
first few were all special events the
category be athletic commercial
community and there are a few more the
event subcategory well sure we've run
into some null values it looks like
maybe only the athletic events have
subcategories then we have the name the
year month app which I believe is an
identifier used by the city the events
start and end dates the park
some events don't have one neighborhood
council district precinct the
organization holding the event and the
estimated attendance so what are we
going to do with this data
well let's build a machine learning
model so to just this talk is mostly
about future engineering part I'll just
use a very simple model will predict a
binary outcome is the permit status
complete or not so did the event
actually happen or did it get canceled
or put on hold for some reason and for
features we can use any of the other
columns we can use them directly apply
various transformations or maybe even
use combinations such as start and end
date together would tell us the length
of the event
so we use scikit-learn to do predictive
modeling and the first step is to split
apart your test and training data and
then set aside your test data and don't
look at it until the end and this way it
through the training process we don't
have to worry about contamination and
when we finally see the test data at the
end we'll know how them all performs on
brand new data so then we'll define the
the outcome using the numpy wear
function this just turns the permit
status whether it's complete or not into
a zero one column and then because this
is very simple model start out with
we'll use the one numeric feature in the
data set which is the attendance and
just in case there are any no values
we'll fill those in with zeros for now
then finally we create a model object
I'll just use the logistic regression
class with the out-of-the-box setting so
no parameter is needed fit the model on
the training data and we can form
predictions so the predict function will
produce a class 0 or 1 and the predict
provo will produce a probability
actually it produces probability of 0
and probability of 1 who will just grab
the second column you can also predict
on the test data alright and this will
help us evaluate how well the model
performs we'll start with the so it's
good to have a baseline if we just come
up with the dumbest model we can think
of how well would that perform so the
simplest model would be let's just
predict the average for everything I'm
going to put the mean from the training
data and we'll just repeat that as many
times as the length of the test dataset
and then of course using the predict
provo function to get the outcomes for
the test data
and then we can evaluate using a you see
there are lots of other evaluation
metrics but this is the one I chose so
the baseline has been AUC is 0.5 and the
very simple 1 variable model has a a you
see 0.58 the maximum possible is 1 so
it's not a great model but for very
little effort we've certainly got
something better than baseline all right
so now let's move on to transformers we
had a one variable model logistic
regression wants all the features to be
numeric so if we didn't have the ability
to do any transformations we basically
be stuck there
luckily scikit-learn provides a whole
bunch of transformers as well as
estimators so these are two very similar
interfaces scikit-learn has a
transformer is for data preparation and
estimator is for modeling they both have
a fit method and what this does is it
takes the training data and finds all
the parameters that the transformer
estimator needs to use in the future and
sometimes transformers don't need any
parameters and then the transformer has
a transform method unsurprisingly and
this applies the transformation to
either the training data or test data or
any new dews that you want and the
estimator in parallel has the predict
method which applies the predictive
model to a the test or training data so
for example one common transformation
you might want to do is a standard
scaler in the fit method it will find
the mean and standard deviation of each
column from the training data and it
saves these values and whenever you call
transform it subtracts that mean and
then divides by that standard deviation
on the new column
what's great about the standard scaler
is it puts all of your features on the
same scale which means say if you're
fitting a regression model you can
interpret the coefficients to be related
to the strength of the future
contributing to the model on the other
side we have an estimator logistic
regression we already took a look at
this one in the fit method we just find
all those coefficients in logistic
regression formula so those data's and
in the predict method we plug in the new
data into that logistic regression
formula and we get the predicted
probability turn that into the
predictive class all right well
sometimes you want to go through
multiple transformations in the course
of feature engineering so see first we
want to impute the missing values and
for that there's built in in puter a
class then maybe we want to throw in
some interactions and square the
variable so by default the polynomial
features class we'll just do the
second-degree polynomial and then
finally a standard scalar at the end
well by the time you've added three
different transformers it can get a bit
clunky so what if we had to put all
these intermediate data sets through the
transformer then we have to remember the
order to apply them to the test data
this would be a pain so luckily
scikit-learn has pipelines pipelines
work is a meta transformer where they
take your whole list of transformers and
apply them in a row and this is how it
works so the pipe on takes a list in
this case we have tuples of the
transformer alias and that to be
whatever you want and then the actual
transformer object and it will apply
these in order
I have to call out a lot of those talk
was inspired by the Zac Stuart blog post
that I linked to here so and then all we
have to do is this we can call fit
transform on the training data which
will apply the fit system transformer
and then apply the transformation and
then we can call transform on the test
data and this is much simpler to write
but sometimes we don't just want to
apply transformations in order sometimes
we want to apply them in parallel this
is not like parallel computation but say
we can't decide which imputation
strategy to use should we impute with
means the median or the most frequent
value well let's just let our machine
learning algorithm choose for us so the
feature Union will put the results of
these three transformers next to each
other so you're going to pull the water
data set and again it takes a list of
the transformer in tuples with their
aliases
and you could just write this fit
transform on the train data transform on
the test data alright so back to the
data set so let's take a look at that
Park column so remember I called out
most of the first at least ahead and 1/2
park and the entire training data set
has almost 400 rows and over 350 of them
are no so I'm using the value count
function here from pandas and then some
of the most common parks to have events
in I include Magnuson gasworks
Occidental Green Lake so we've got maybe
40 rows that have a park but Seattle has
over 400 parks so there's a pretty good
chance that our test data is going to
have some parks in it that we've never
seen before and it's important that our
transformer know how to handle that
gracefully another interesting column is
Leah tendon so this is the one I used
before so I filled in the nulls with
zeros let's see how many times I did
that so just call is null on the penis'
series and that will produce a boolean
just sum them up it happened to be three
nulls
so I guess most of the time people
estimate their attendance and then I can
use the plot function to take a look at
the distribution so here's the
distribution of attendance on the raw
scale the danger with having this as a
input feature is the events with the
really high attendance apparently goes
up to 200 thousand and potentially can
have high influence over your model
because they're so far away from the
other data points if these have an
unusual value the predictions could get
pulled towards it so here it is on the
log scale this looks much
closer to normal and this is probably a
better feature to use so now we've got a
bunch of different transformers on our
tool kit let's see what we want to do
what if the transformation you want to
do is not implemented you scour the
psychic learn documentation you can't
find it well one thing to check is can
you use the function transformer so this
is a generic transformer that
scikit-learn provides and you can just
give it a function and it will apply
that function to the whole data set so
for example we want to use this log 1p
which adds one to your X variable and
then logs it so it means that the zeros
won't result in negative infinity values
so all you have to do is create a
function transformer object pass in that
function and then you can call transform
with it or you can write your own custom
transformer so this is a very simple
example obviously we just did it with a
function transformer you don't need to
but just start out so we'll create a
class called log 1p transformer and it
will inherit from the transformer mixin
so the transformer mixin will take the
fit and transform methods and
automatically create see fit underscore
transform method which is just a
convenience method the fit method
doesn't need to do anything because
there aren't any parameters that the
transform a needs to know from the
training data the transform method all
it does is call the function on your
data set and return it so super simple
but they lays out the structure for are
we going to do about that Park column so
the idea is to use one hot encoding this
is also called dummy encoding the idea
is instead of having a single column
with a bunch of strings in it we make
one
for gasworks with a swag zero one wall
and column from Magnussen one column for
each of the park so we see in the
training data and there's a great
built-in transformer that does this
called the dict vectorizer but the dict
vectorizer doesn't have the input and
output we want so we'll create a class
and create a field to hold that internal
transformer and call it the dummy
transformer we take the X data which
will be a bunch of string columns and
turn each of those into each row of that
data set and to record a mapping from
the column name to the column value this
is the format the disk vectorizer wants
so we fit it and then we return the
transformer object in the transform
method we again turn our data set into
records dictionary records and then call
the transform on that internal
transformer go grab the feature name
that it produces so this will say like
event Park location equals Magnuson
event park location equals gasworks and
pull the index from the original data
set and just goes back on and turn it
back into a data frame so
all right so I've hinted at the the
complication of using pandas and
pipelines together well dig a little bit
more into it so pandas dataframes
support many data types
whereas scikit-learn models usually
expect all the features be numeric
pandas dataframes allow for missing data
but most scikit-learn models can't
handle nulls and finally pandas
dataframes have labeled rows and columns
which is really useful when you want to
interpret your model if it says Oh
feature 42 is really important
great what the heck is feature 42
scikit-learn models will downcast in
transformers will downcast to numpy
arrays which strip out these labels we
really want to put those back on so
unsurprisingly the solution is custom
transformers the key here is pipelines
are already pandas friendly meaning they
will take a data frame and return a data
frame if all this component transformers
are so we just have to write a bunch of
custom transformers that return data
frames and then we can stay in pandas
land for the whole machine learning
process so there are a few different
reasons we might want to write the
custom transformer and we just want to
pull out the column so we want to work
with wrap existing transformers to
reapply those labels or some more
complex logic say the transformer you
want really is not implemented well you
can go implement it yourself all right
so here's the column extractor so all
this does is pull out the columns we
want to work with and this is very
useful for future portions of pipelines
so a sip method doesn't do anything the
initializer we just give it the list of
columns we want in a transform takes the
pandas dataframe and slices to those
columns and here's the standard scalar
so standard scalar is one of those
transformers there
numpy array so we'll just wrap it with a
custom transformer will create a feel
for that standard skill or to live in so
the fit method will just fit it and save
it and then for the transform method
would transform with that internal
standard scaler
and then put the index and the column
names back on great so now let's put it
all together and fit a more complex
predictive model so I'll make a list of
the categorical features we've got the
permit type the event category and
subcategory the park in the neighborhood
and then the numeric features will the
only one was to attendance so now we'll
create our feature engineering pipeline
so this pipeline has two components it
has the features which is a data frame
friendly feature Union and the code for
that is in the github repo and the
second element is this standard scalar
and then inside that feature Union we
have the categorical pipeline in the
numeric pipeline in the categorical
pipeline first we extract the columns
and then we apply that dummy transformer
in the numeric pipeline we extract the
columns we apply this zero fill
transformer which I also wrote and then
apply the log 1p so now that we have
that trans the whole transformation
process wrapped up in that pipeline we
can apply it to the training data just
transform the test data with it and use
the logistic regression again fit the
model predict on the test data and our
AUC has gone up from point five eight
two point seven one so pulling and all
those extra features helped and that's
all I've got so here's a link to my
github repo if you're interested they're
a whole variety of additional
transformer
and I also have examples of transforming
almost all the features in the data set
we are only able to touch on a few happy
to take questions Julie oh so well
everyone in the room tweets any
questions you might have on going on the
livestream question I want to lead off
with is give any recommendations or
anything to deal with potential
performance bottlenecks or issues you
might typically run into when doing this
that people should probably be aware of
when they start with this so they don't
get bogged down and trying to deal with
some slow model or anything yeah so the
idea here would be implement your
transformer the simplest way first and
then if that's slow try to go in and
optimize it it will just depend on your
data set I got mine fast enough that I
could use them for some all I was
working on and I stopped there but I you
know before putting this into open
source you know some official version
you should definitely go through and
make optimized another question I had
was one of the jokes in the earlier
opening keynote was about pandas API not
being widely loved yeah do you have any
guidelines or anything on how to kind of
work around it or deal with it if you
happen to be bumping up against and
having some issues working with it by
any chance yes so so pandas has a
variety of different ways to access the
columns and sometimes one works and
another doesn't so that's always fun if
so do you use the sort of structure of
the pipeline and you've already q8 each
of the individual components then you
know it's all going to work
I don't know whether complaints to
people of Pettis I really like having my
columns labeled I think that's just
super useful in evaluating how the mall
is performing trying to understand what
the most important features are and so
on
especially when you introduce new
features or your filter out other ones
so one question we did get from the
audience is for custom transformers that
input data frames output data frames
what is the memory usage typically and
is it covered back and forth or are they
using references okay so so so the
transformation method is going to be
whatever you write and I imagine it is
copying but you could probably write a
more efficient one if you wanted
Christmas just asked with any questions
from the audience specifically said we
can repeat yes just sort of build on
that last one is it possible to adapt
this to situations where you have a date
that it will not fit in memory test so
the question was if you have a data set
as like an example now that it's too big
to fit memory would need to be streamed
how would you handle that well I
personally haven't worked a lot of
streaming data sets but so the pipeline
is pretty flexible if you can wrap maybe
you don't want to be transforming pandas
dataframes maybe you want to be
returning transforming some sort of
streaming object and so I imagine you
could put that into a pipeline instead
and use the same sort of structure
using farther question rather than I
can't okay the question was why would
you use a dummy transformer instead of a
regression tree method so can you
explain me what what you would do the
regression tree right so so the idea
with the one hot encoding was that I
want to put these in to say well my
example was a logistic regression with a
lot of other features in in that case it
does want the numeric encoding and
people have asked me why will you use
this form of one hot encoding instead of
one of the built-in ones so I have a
couple slides if you're interested I
don't know sure we have lots of time
because I went faster than I was
expecting
all right so
pandas has the get dummy's this will
work on a single data set but it's not
really good for applying it to a new
data set so I can't learn pre-processing
has a label encoder and a one hot
encoder but both of using these together
it arrows out if there are new levels in
the data set in the test data and then
finally the dict vectorizer I ended up
having to wrap with the transformations
on each end to get the data in the right
format but that was the one that worked
best for me
one question being had from Twitter was
talking about how you handle unseen
categories with one hot encoding in your
test data yeah so what I did is
basically give them all zeros but there
are other options too you could use a
feature hasher instead of one hot
encoder so what that will do is put all
of your features into bins so so
hopefully the really common ones will
end up in different bins from each other
it's a it's a good high dimensional
approximation of one hot encoding and
then you don't have explosion of your
data set size the other thing you can do
is you can create one more column to
indicate whether the value through the
park was n a versus a new value
another question we got was how do you
decide on the number of engineered
features you want and not get too many
in the end alright so I like to start
with as many features as possible and
then let my machine learning algorithm
try to whittle it down and in fact in
the in the extended code on the github
where I transform it almost all the
columns the performance starts degrading
its I think it's the point six nine AUC
and so at that point we're already
starting to overfit
you could add a higher penalty to the
logistic regression to whittle down the
number of features I would say you know
I put in as much time as you feel like
into the future engineering and see how
it does and serve iterate back and forth
to the point where you're happy with
your model were there any other
questions from the image yeah I find I
don't like it so the question was says
Julie ever put a psychic pipeline
psych-k clarin pipeline into production
and if so how
alright so you can just one way to do
this would be to save your transformer
object and keep it running in Python I
think you can you can serialize them
depending depending on what the inputs
are anyhow so you could it's pretty easy
to spin up a pipeline and you can then
put that on some instance in the cloud
and use use that as your score you could
put an API in front of it and score that
way another way to use this is just to
write down your resultant model and all
the transformations that you ended up
needing to house at the end as I said I
used
throw in as many features as I can and
then we'll it down and just translate it
into another language yes so the
question was does it really have any
plans to take her wrappers and release
it as an independent package I I haven't
thought about that far yet but it is it
is all on github and you're free to
download them so the way the way I
usually do this is I put all the custom
transformers in a separate file and then
I import which ever ones I want to use
yes
right okay so can you repeat the
question
so the question was again about the
dummy transformer if I look back to that
Oh too far okay so in the dummy
transformer what it does is it creates a
flag column for each of the parks that
would show up in the tests are in the
training data and so when a new value
comes along all all the dicks truck
driver is going to do is say I've ever
heard of this value you get zeros for
each of those flag columns and so
depending on if you do have na s the the
sector Iser will create a another column
that indicates whether the the original
column was na or not and there are two
ways to handle that you can either drop
it or you can turn it into a flag it
originally it's encoded as a zero na
which is not useful because we don't
want nulls you can turn it into a zero
one did you
yes so so the training data is not going
to have this scenario happen where it's
an unknown park because you built the
transformer on the training data below
then you apply it to a new data set it
will have to know how to handle those
new values that come in and not I just
not error out there I mean there are
other options for handling it you just
you need something that your program
doesn't crash okay well as you can
probably see out the window it's time
for lunch so let's think to the one more
time for giving the talk now for
everyone here and those on the live
stream there will still be things
happening during lunch there's going to
be interviews being held so if you are
here at the conference you can go to
cascade and have your lunch in there and
watch the interviews that are going to
be recorded and obviously those in your
live stream just please stay tuned and
wait watch for those thank you